COUNTRY DO NOT FEEL SAFE.
>> I THINK WOMEN DON'T FEEL SAFE
BECAUSE IT IS NOT A SAFE PLACE
FOR WOMEN AND STATISTICS BEAR
OUT ON THAT.
LEVELS OF VIOLENCE ARE HIGH AND
SEXUAL VIOLENCE ARE VERY HUL.
THAT'S WHY WOMEN DON'T FEEL
SAFE.
>> YOU'VE DRAWN A LINK BETWEEN
HIGH LEVELS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
IN PLACES LIKE NAMIBIA AND SOUTH
AFRICA AND APARTHEID.
I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
SOME PEOPLE WOULDN'T
AUTOMATICALLY DRAW PARALLELS
BETWEEN.
WALK US THROUGH THAT.
>> MANY PEOPLE DON'T REALIZE
NAMIBIA WAS A FOOT PROVENS OF
SOUTH AFRICA, HAD THE SAME
LEGALIZED WITH MINISTERS, AND
ZAIN, I THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT
BECAUSE THERE WAS A LOT OF
STRUCTURAL VIOLENCE AS PART OF
APARTHEID.
THERE WAS MY GRANT LABOR SYSTEMS
THAT DESTROYED FAMILIES AND MOST
TELLING, I THINK THE STRUCTURE
OF NAMIBIA, WE ALL KNOW EVIDENCE
SHOWS COUNTRIES THAT HAVE HIGH
LEVELS OF INEQUALITY HAVE HIGH
LEVELS OF VIOLENCE.
I OFTEN THINK WHEN WE HAVE THE
DISCUSSION ABOUT VIOLENCE IN
NAMIBIA AND SOUTH AFRICA, WE
OFTEN FORGET WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT POST CONFLICT SOCIETIES
WITH ALL OF THE PROBLEMS RELATED
TO POST CONFLICT SOCIETIES.
>> WE TALK ABOUT ABUSE AGAINST
WOMEN IN NAMIBIA.
YES, OBVIOUSLY PHYSICAL ABUSE IS
ONE IMPORTANT STRAND, BUT ALSO
VERBAL ABUSE.
AS FIRST LADY, YOU HAVE BEEN
CALLED A SLUT, CALLED TOO FAT,
YOU HAVE BEEN CALLED TOO UGLY,
YOU HAVE BEEN CALLED
MANIPULATIVE, CORRUPT.
PEOPLE HAVE SAID THAT YOUR
MARRIAGE TO THE PRESIDENT IS A
SHAM.
YOU HAVE RECEIVED ALL KINDS OF
HORRIFIC ONLINE ABUSE AND I KNOW
THAT A LOT OF WOMEN IN POWER
THAT HAVE TO DEAL WITH ABUSE ON
SOCIAL MEDIA, A LOT OF TIMES
THEY KEEP SILENT.
YOU HAVE CHOSEN NOT TO KEEP
SILENT.
YOU HAVE SPOKEN OUT ABOUT THIS
RECENTLY IN A VIDEO THAT SORT OF
WENT SOMEWHAT VIRAL.
WALK US THROUGH WHY YOU HAVE
CHOSEN NOT TO BE SILENT.
>> SO LIKE MOST PEOPLE I WAS
TOLD NOT TO SPEAK UP, TO IGNORE
IT.
AND I REALIZED IT WAS GETTING
WORSE.
AND I DECIDED IF THIS IS MY
EXPERIENCE, I WONDER HOW MANY
OTHER WOMEN ARE HAVING THE SAME
EXPERIENCE AND BEING SILENCED.
I FELT A RESPONSIBILITY TO SPEAK
BECAUSE I FELT THERE WERE FEWER
CONSEQUENCES FOR ME TO SAY WHAT
I SAID IN THE VIDEO WHERE I
ADDRESSED THOSE SLURS AND TO SAY
THAT WHEN WE ARE SILENT, WE
ALLOW OTHER WOMEN TO THINK THAT
MAYBE THEY'RE THE PROBLEM.
WHY DO OTHER WOMEN EXPERIENCE
WHAT I AM EXPERIENCING.
BY SPEAKING UP, THERE WAS
AVALANCHE OF RESPONSE FROM MEN
AND WOMEN.
FEW PEOPLE UNDERSTOOD HOW TOXIC
AND VILE ONLINE HARASSMENT IS
AND THE VIDEO SHOWS HOW COMMON
IT IS FOR EVERYBODY.
I WAS CONCERNED BY HOW MANY
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO WANT TO ENGAGE
IN POLITICS, WHO WANT TO FLY
HIGH WERE STARTING TO SAY I
DON'T WANT TO BE POLITICALLY
ENGAGED, IF THIS IS WHAT YOU ARE
GOING THROUGH AND YOU ARE FIRST
LADY, THE SYSTEM CAN'T PROTECT
YOU, HOW WILL I BE PROTECTED.
AND THAT WILL BE A SAD DAY IF WE
ALLOW ONLINE HARASSMENT TO
EFFECTIVELY SILENCE WOMEN
BECAUSE THAT'S THE INTENT.
THE INTENT ISN'T BECAUSE THEY
REALLY BELIEVE I AM UGLY OR
REALLY BELIEVE I AM FAT, REALLY
BELIEVE I AM GOLD DIGGER BECAUSE
EVIDENCE WILL BE OUT THAT NONE
OF THAT IS TRUE.
THE INTENT IS TO KEEP QUIET,
KNOW YOUR PLACE, AND STOP
SPEAKING SO MUCH.
>> YOU TALKED ABOUT THE FACT
THAT IT IS NOT ENOUGH TO HAVE
WOMEN SUPPORT WOMEN WHEN IT
COMES TO GENDER BASED VIOLENCE,
FEMACIDE, IMPORTANT TO MAKE SURE
MEN ARE INVOLVED TOO.
YOUR HUSBAND IS THE MOST
POWERFUL MAN IN YOUR COUNTRY,
HE'S THE PRESIDENT.
HOW IS HE SUPPORTING THIS ISSUE?
>> HE IS THE MOST POWERFUL MAN
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY THAN THAT,
HIS PERSONAL VALUE SYSTEM, AND
HE HAS GENERALLY GOTTEN A VERY
PROGRESSIVE, HE HAS A VERY
PROGRESSIVE UNDERSTANDING AND
ACCEPTANCE OF THESE TYPE OF
ISSUES.
I THINK IT REFLECTS ITSELF IN
THE NATURE OF OUR RELATIONSHIP.
I DON'T THINK MANY SPOUSES CAN
SAY THE TYPE OF THINGS I SAY
WITHOUT SOME FORM OF MODERATION
FROM THEIR SPOUSE.
IT IS NOT THAT HE DOESN'T HAVE
THE VIEWS, BUT HE CERTAINLY DOES
RESPECT MINE.
>> BEYOND SORT OF SUPPORTING YOU
IN YOUR ENDEAVORS TO PROMOTE
GENDER EQUALITY IN THE COUNTRY,
HOW HAS HE SHOWN AS PRESIDENT
PRACTICAL SUPPORT FOR THE ISSUE?
>> SO APART FROM NAMIBIA BEING I
THINK THE SECOND OR THIRD
COUNTRY IN AFRICA WITH THE
HIGHEST FEMALE REPRESENTATION IN
PARLIAMENT, HE IS APPOINTED
WOMEN TO POWERFUL POSITIONS.
OUR PRIME MINISTER IS A WOMAN,
USED TO BE THE MINISTER OF
FINANCE.
BOTH MINISTERS OF EDUCATION ARE
WOMEN.
DEPUTY PRIME MINISTER WHO IS
ALSO THE VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
RULING PARTY IS A WOMAN.
HE IS REALLY POPULATED POWERFUL
PORTFOLIOS WITH COMPETENT AND
ABLE FEMALE REPRESENTATION.
SO WE HAVE A LOT OF WOMEN IN
POWERFUL POSITIONS, WHICH
REFLECTS HIS VIEW THAT WE MUST
HAVE A